tropical storm laura has already had a
deadly impact on its way to the u.s
killing at least 11 people in the
dominican republic
and in haiti janet chamlion reports from
new orleans where louisiana's governor
is warning of a powerful one-two punch
from laura and marco
tropical storm laura ripped across the
island of hispaniola sunday
rushing water overtaking the streets of
haiti
trash everywhere the bodies of victims
laid out along the side of a road
the storm slammed the dominican republic
flooding
as far as the eye can see more than a
million lost power
homes ruined more lives lost
hurricane hunters flew through laura for
a closer look
this is somewhat unprecedented
scope of the storms and president trump
approved an emergency declaration for
louisiana
as it braces for both laura and tropical
storm marco
residents of low-lying areas have been
ordered to evacuate
the storms looming as this week marks 15
years since new orleans was devastated
by hurricane katrina
for some the anxiety still fresh
i just feel afraid i'm going to lose my
house and i don't have anywhere to go
right now especially with the
virus this area is expected to be
slammed by heavy rain coastal flooding
and potentially even tornadoes
and the louisiana governor is now saying
that the window between the two storms
could be as slim as 12 hours and of
course it's coming during
a pandemic that is an added stress on
the region as people are leaving their
homes and heading into shelters
tony yeah and the time to prepare is now
janet thank you very much